foreign
some of you are new to this and we've
got literally millions of you joining us
in the last couple of months thank you
we're so glad you're here and we want
the opportunity to love you an
opportunity to help you
um and and sometimes you get in here and
you hear information that's new to you
it's a new way of thinking and uh for
some folks in our culture today that
that's not a challenge because they're
looking for new information they're
looking for a new way of looking at
things other times it's a challenge for
you because you get all Disturbed and
you think it becomes your job then to
get us to change
um you got confused about how this
relationship works
okay because this is called the Ramsey
show this is what the this this is who
we are and what we teach if you want to
do a show go do a show okay but get some
hate at the break no I just I always get
hate I've gotten hate for 30 years
you're gonna get a hate after that last
call like you you always get haters to
bring this whole thing up you get
trashed on this stuff and uh but that
the whole point is let me help you with
this I for
30 years every letter that has come to
Ramsey
to me has been answered
except junk mail and hate mail
there's no reason to answer hate mail
and there's no reason to answer idiots
in the comments section of YouTube
okay there's no reason because let me
just
did you think we were going to change
because of you little troll
you got confused how this works we're
not going to change because we're right
so you that's why you came here in the
first place because you wanted new
information because the information you
were using sucked and so did your life
and so we're here to help you with that
it's what we do and and so but don't get
confused
how about this stuff it's it's just
hilarious to me that I was just reading
but there are things you learn in life I
learned I learned on the air something
yesterday okay and I would love to hear
it and so I don't mind learning but the
but I didn't learn it from a troll
sure okay and I didn't and so and I
didn't learn it from an activist oh give
me a break get a job
um so so just you know I was just
thinking about how much crap you're
gonna catch
you actually see it but I don't even see
it because I don't even look if you read
comments after an article you understand
why some species kill their young I mean
it's just un the the ignorance that
abounds out there is unbelievable so uh
the interesting thing about this uh you
know the last 25 or 30 years we've all
grown up uh some of you have grown up
with and I've adapted as an old fart to
walking around with this magic wand in
my hand
and so I can push a button and stuff
shows up on my front porch
I'm magic
and so I must matter
I've got great power
no you really don't do you think that's
where it comes from yeah oh I guarantee
you we gave people agency beyond their
ability to control it we gave them
autonomy beyond their ability to control
it and thus they become trolls because
someone they thought they got confused
and thought someone cared what they
thought Hey listen you live in your
mother's basement I don't care what you
think
it's not I'm sorry
you haven't earned the right to speak
into this yet okay so that's that just
to go ahead and help you guys that are
new how this stuff works well you're
arrogant no I'm just confident there's a
difference
arrogance is unfounded
okay we've been doing this 30 freaking
years and the prince yes and yes works
and the principles work and they're
they're biblically based common sense
when things used to not be so nutty out
there and this agency and autonomy we've
given to people who have to have an
opinion and to speak in and to raise
hell with people uh when they haven't
earned the right to do it uh is not good
for our culture
it's damaging our culture because then
people are actually being swayed by
crazy people
the mob and so it's hard to cancel us we
own this and we're not going to stop
so if you don't like it your only option
is leave
because we don't even care if you
it doesn't bother us so just kind of
helping you guys sit out about others
work so I think other Scouts every so
often we have to reset reset the
equation here man you drop the b word
Dave so I mean it's it's okay Life's
good Life's good it is and listen
it's fine see I it's so fun I'm like
just it's just different personalities
if if there are people that
totally disagree and they think we're
nuts I'm like that's great I don't
that's fine you can think we're nuts ah
just go somewhere else
why are you wasting your breath that's
my point yeah Move Along little doggy
yeah so there we go